a lot of our gun control measures are
aimed at people who would obey the law
and get the permits
how does keep a veer you from having a
gun really controlled gun violence in
Washington or New York City
I have Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Craig or
Whitney he's the author of living with
guns a liberals case for the Second
Amendment Craig thanks for talking to us
thank you for having me
liberals case for the Second Amendment
tell us briefly what is your liberal
case for this my liberal case is that it
is an individual right it's a common law
right recognized by the Second Amendment
but the right existed from Jamestown
right talk about some of the early
attempts to kind of create gun control
one of the things that's fascinating is
that they you know follow kind of
predictable patterns of you know we
don't want blacks to have guns we don't
want to Italian immigrants because they
have poor impulse control to have guns
talk talk a bit about the history of gun
control well you couldn't have a gun if
you were a black even a freed man before
the Civil War
Catholics couldn't have guns in the New
England colonies gun control always
existed because you had you had to serve
in the militia if you were a white male
18 or over and you had to have a gun and
the people in the towns who had the
malicious knew who had guns and and
where they were so there was a gun
registry system in in the old militia
days serious gun control didn't really
come into play until after the Civil War
and reconstruction in the First World
War
and prohibition so you had organized
crime and a lot of gunfire with tommy
guns and sawed-off shotguns that well
the gun control act was meant to yeah
and I mean in a way gun control is also
as a result of the urbanization of
America because suddenly you have a lot
of people living in close proximity well
you know and this comes out from a
libertarian perspective people you know
are I think familiar mostly with the to
to kind of phrases one that's variously
attributed to Robert Heinlein or William
Burroughs that
armed society is a polite society but
also that if you outlaw guns only
outlaws have guns is that by and large
true that most people who carry guns
actually are law-abiding citizens sure I
mean in the whole country at large
definitely the the problem of gun
violence is largely an urban problem of
illegal guns guns that people own that
never had the right to buy them and that
aren't registered and a lot of our gun
control measures are aimed at people who
would obey the law and get the permits
how do you make sense of the fact that
over the past ten years twenty years
we've seen an increase a surge in gun
ownership in America and a decrease in
gun-related crime it you know does that
make sense or those I live you scratch v
the armed society is a polite society
crowd would tell you that's because of
that the criminals don't know if you're
armed or unarmed and so they are less
likely to use guns in an assault against
you but I think the reason for the
decline in violence for the most part
it's been a decline over the last 10 or
20 years it's because of the ebbing of
the crack epidemic and the surge in
violence gun violence before that was
due to the epidemic itself people talk
about being First Amendment absolutist
totally in favor of free speech say
you're not a second Amendment absolutist
talk a little bit about what you
consider our kind of common sense
restrictions on gun ownership I think
the the requirement that you your name
has to be checked with a database that
the FBI maintains to make sure that you
before you buy a gun from a federally
licensed dealer that you're not a drug
addict that you're not under a
restraining order of some kind from a
court and that you're not mentally ill
adjudicated what about the politics of
gun control one of the kind of subtext
of the most recent presidential election
was hey you know when Obama gets
reelected he's going to grab your guns
the fact of the matter is is that over
the past twenty five years most states
have vastly liberalized their gun laws
that the Supreme Court recently and a
couple of edom really surprising and
large decisions have said hey
you know second Amendment right is a
constitutional right it's an individual
right to bear arms are we past gun
ownership as a political issue or where
is that gonna absolutely not because of
the NRA mm-hmm in what way
well the NRA I belong to the NRA and and
all during the the twenty twelve
election campaign they were bombarding
me and everybody else who belongs with
appeals for money to defeat Obama
because Obama was going to take away our
gun rights and all our other rights
literally so well you get the guns first
then you can take away all the baby but
because of that they use the fear they
spread fear it helps raise money and and
the reaction from people who are now
going out to buy guns because they
believe this you know he's now he's
reelected he's that's gonna be harder to
get the newspaper reports have been
filled for the past four years or so
with people by an increase in a huge
increase the Black Friday numbers were
apparently higher than even ever before
and yet Obama has done nothing often to
the kind of despair of many of his
liberal supporters who want you know
they thought that was part of the deal
he actually in his first term all he did
was sign two measures affecting guns one
allows you to carry a gun in a loaded in
a locked container onto an Amtrak train
and another one largely to take a gun
into a national park how is that taking
away people's gold what about at the
local level or at the state level are we
likely to see you know kind of new gun
control measures in various cities and
states I mean Chicago which was the site
of one of the other big gun control
Supreme Court cases are they gonna keep
coming back and trying to maintain very
strict gun control and if so will it be
yes just as they did in the District of
Columbia after the Heller ruling in Oh 8
the the district came back with a new
set of regulations that you don't ban
handguns absolutely but they do ban
assault so-called assault weapons even
in the Heller ruling Justice Scalia's
ruling said that you know reasonable gun
control measures are
unconstitutional what is your favorite
shooting experience that you've had I
used an ak-47 modified at a range in
Arizona in Phoenix a couple of years ago
and that was great fun shooting at
targets I mean it can be fun well I want
to thank Craig or Whitney the author of
living with guns a liberals case for the
Second Amendment for talking to Reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie thank you very
much